cinéma maintenant avec l'émergence d'un
nouveau talent la drôle et pétillante
cécile de france
à 26 ans elle s'offre le luxe d'être à
la fiche de trois films en trois
semaines cet élève de la rue blanche qui
s'est investie cette semaine dans la
promotion du film
irène richard tripot gens vers l'arrière
elle s'appelle cécile de france mais
elle est belge né à namur il ya 26 ans
déjà remarqué il ya deux ans dans le
film de richard berry l'art délicat de
la séduction elle s'impose aujourd'hui
dans le rôle d'irène une trentenaire un
peu goualich à la recherche du grand
amour
je ne vois pas pourquoi vous ne valez
pas de crier du cac à nos vues non chez
décrié holla holla êtes vous là bas
aulas vient bien parce que elle est
touchante par sa maladresse elle ose
quand même aller aller de l'avant pour
elle aussi se planter brian tous et une
feria un petit peu après dix ans de
théâtre en belgique et à paris cécile de
france a enchaîné les rôles au cinéma
pas moins de trois films tournés l'année
dernière
dans l'auberge espagnole le dernier film
de cédric klapisch
elle est cette jeune étudiante belge qui
aiment plutôt les filles quand je trouve
chaque sexe est dans son coin sans
s'intéresser va me l'autre c'est assez
fatigant de faire trois promouvoir trois
films en même temps les interviews
l'avion et où j'ai pas l'habitude donc
ça me mais je suis super contente les
gens sont à chaumont gentil et la
semaine prochaine on retrouvera cécile
de france dans le premier long métrage
de luc pagès a plus policé lessard et
j'espère la dans la tête elle et pollux
une femme mystérieuse et sauva dix ans
après son arrivée à paris cécile de
france accumule donc les succès des
succès qui lui font un peu peur d'être
égocentrique tout cas de plus en plus
parce qu'à force qu'on ne parle que de
vous toute la journée j'ai peur de me
refermer sur moi-même et de plus
m'intéresser aux autres et ça je
voudrais surtout pas pour rien au monde
sa marine mademoiselle cécile de france
généreuse et spontanée gay cécile de
france se souviendra sûrement longtemps
de ce mois de juin où elle est entrée
dans la cour des grandes dents